Senate Judiciary Committee chairman
Lindsey Graham is with a senator
we're losing 300 people a week because
of opioid addiction in this country okay
then we have sanctuary cities and states
right we have violent criminals that are
released and they create they commit
more violent crimes right I would argue
they would argue if it was us they would
have blood on their hands there are
accomplices and what they do post that
moment when we couldn't deport them and
we don't we protect them aiding and
abetting in crime how does that stop
well this is the defining issue of the
election among many the Republican Party
is saying if you're a sanctuary city and
you refuse to work with the federal
government to turn over violent felons
so they can be incarcerated and deported
if you refuse to help the federal
government we're going to cut off all
federal funds let's take that to the
ballot box there are men and women being
killed raped and murdered by felons in
sanctuary cities who the local
government refuses to turn over the
felon to the federal government they
stay in the city and they rape and
murder and kill and Rob and to me the
president is dead right about this and
he should take that the Biden and take
that to Bernie and say what's your
position on this you know we now you've
known Joe Biden for many many years you
have many many years we see the gaffes
we now see Ron Johnson's committee
looking into barrese mo billion-dollars
fire the prosecutor investigating my
zero experience Sunday paid millions if
that was Donald Trump I think we'd have
different reaction from the Democrats so
we got Biden as he I will be my honest
opinion
his gaffes are now officially very
alarming
whether he's up to the job the toughest
job in the world then he has a record
that will be compared to presidents
Trump not very good on either foreign
policy or economically tell us about the
Joe Biden you know and the one that
wants open borders and sanctuary cities
and free health care for illegal
immigrants well the Joe Biden oh I like
personally but I think he's been a
disaster on national security it was Joe
Biden who convinced Obama to pull all of
our troops out of Iraq yes Joe Biden
who's responsible for the rise of
as much as any single American
politician Joe Biden supported the Iran
nuclear agreement Joe Biden allows
illegal immigrants free health care Joe
Biden would cancel the program in place
where if you're seeking asylum you have
to wait in Mexico so the biggest thing
President Trump has done it's not just
build wall remember about six months ago
when hundreds of thousands people were
coming here warning to get caught
claiming asylum and we had to turn him
loose in our country and they never
showed up for the hearing it was
President Trump who convinced Mexico to
allow us to keep them in Mexico until
their hearing so they don't run around
and get loose in our country that's the
biggest change in immigration in the
last 30 or 40 years and Joe Biden says
he would terminate that program free
health care amnesty open borders Wow 90%
of America's heroin comes from there the
FISA Court you're beginning your process
of investigating that after the
inspector general's report we're waiting
for Durham we're waiting for the
Attorney General bar but the FISA Court
has spoken out today it's a very strong
language we'll get into the details
coming up what did you think of that new
development today the FISA Court
speaking out and will we ever get to
hear from the judges that were lied to
well so here's here's what I think I
think the court has to prove to the
public at large that they're capable of
doing something about the abuse that
came their way here's what I'm trying to
find out more than anything else in
January 2017 the primary sub source a
Russian who gave all the information
regarding the dossier to Christopher
steel tells the FBI that it's a bunch of
bar talk I want to know what happened
after that how could Comey McCabe not
know that the entire case fell apart I
don't believe this possible at all for
the higher-ups not to be told that the
entire case collapsed in January 2017
top of a FISA warrant I've been told
I've never seen one says verify we now
know it was unverifiable we know the
remote warnings that would say I go back
to October pre-meditated fraud can I add
something to that
yeah we know that the person who
prepared them for May
said it wasn't reliable the person who
gave still the entire information said
to the FBI and Department of Justice
this is Bartok I never meant it to be
used to get a warrant we know that and
they went ahead and got two more
warrants after they knew that
premeditated fraud on it yes denying an
individual's constitutional rights to
YES on a candidate a transition team in
a president yes it all happily all right
they better pay a price we've otherwise
we don't have a constitution